hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
kurzes galileo team bei mir und wir
haben einen beitrag zusammen gefilmt zum
thema crowd fitting also lauter rezepte
die man gut vorbereiten kann die schnell
sind mit wenigen zutaten mit wenig
aufwand mit denen man eine ganz große
menschenmenge glücklich machen kann und
es ging um desserts um süße speisen und
ich habe unter anderem einen riesen
sneakers regel gemacht und möchte euch
in diesem video heute zeigen wie ich den
schritt für schritt gemacht habe als ich
habe schon öfters gemacht und das war so
eine original trifft sally folgende
nachgemacht reihe von nicht auf das war
vor zwei jahren
ich glaube auch ich glaube vor über zwei
jahren weil da waren wir noch in der
alten wohnung glaube ich und jeden fall
habe ich damals diese kleinen slickers
gemacht in kleine portionen was ich
persönlich auch viel hübscher finde weil
sie erstens viel handlicher sind und
zweitens sieht hübsch aus
natürlich ist es viel mehr aufwand
kleine sneakers regel zu machen und
jeden sneakers regel 1 einzeln zu
überziehen
aber jetzt zwar gewünscht dass ich eben
crowdfunding desserts mache die eben
schnell gehen deswegen ein großer
sneakers riegel und das ist er
und es sieht es von außen eher
unscheinbar aus aber wir werden ihnen ja
gleich am ende dass wir das abseilen für
leute die sich wissen was kraut muss
nicht wissen erklärt ja viele viele
personelle person war dieses thema nicht
zu er ist griffig aber wir sind hier
also einen deutschland bisher für viele
menschen genau mit wenig aufwand ja auf
jeden fall schneiden wir das am ende des
videos an
also dieser sneakers regel reicht mal
locker fechten locker 40 personen
und falls ihr den jetzt nicht ganz so
groß machen wollt können ihn auch
kleiner machen mit einer kleineren form
ich habe eine ganz normalen kasten
kuchenformen besten benutzt ihr könnt
aber zum beispiel auch nähe zur wahl
stelle
was steckdose der kunststoff dose
benutzen oder auch den riegel einfrieren
es geht auch so genau
ich finde dass er richtig mächtig also
abschied nicht ganz gaza lecker trotzdem
sehr gut ab und absoluter augenschmaus
die leute die hier mitten im haus und es
ist das tolle ist weil ich ja schon
kenia schmeckt das thema aber erst am 11
ich zeige euch jetzt am besten erstmal
die 2
haben für die erste schicht bevor ich
jetzt mit der ersten schicht beginnt
muss ich jetzt erst mal eine passende
format befinden
und ich nehme jetzt ganz eine ganz
normale kastenform die eignet sich
hervorragend für so einen riesen sneaker
und die muss jetzt erstmal mit
backpapier auslegen damit ich später die
sneaker den riesenflieger soll wieder
rausbekommen
da geht es jetzt ein bisschen
wachstumsbereich nur damit dem
backpapier eben jetzt auch gut haftet
dann und backpapier nehmen
das baltic wird vorher passt besser rein
und hier am rand befestige ich dann mit
so haarklammern also dass ein paar
klammern aber ich habe die immerhin der
küche und benutzte auch noch hinweg kann
man das backpapier nämlich ein bisschen
infizieren
jetzt sieht es so aus
damit setzt hier rechts und links nicht
angeht habe ich jetzt hier noch ein
backpapier starten und den werde ich
jetzt
habe ich die form ausgelegten kann
bereits mit der ersten schicht beginnen
und zwar müsste ich euch das so
vorstellen
die geschichten werden jetzt hier
eingeführt und später wird es eher
umgedreht das heißt die geschichte jetzt
ganz unten ist ist später ganz oben
deswegen werde ich jetzt zuerst einmal
die karamell schicht herstellen ließ
nämlich beim richtigen sneakers auch
ganz oben
und dafür habe ich es hier drei zutaten
und 220 gramm kondensmilch 600 gramm
karamellbonbons und 400 gramm gesalzene
erdnüsse
es ist ganz wichtig dass die erdnüsse
gesalzen sind ansonsten wird das nix
riegel spielt einfach viel zu mächtig
und dieses salz hebt zwar auch die süße
aber gleicht auch gleichzeitig den
geschmack ein bisschen aus die car
menschlich könnte jetzt auch einfach aus
sahne und zucker herstellen
aber da müsstet ihr vorher so einen
zuckersirup herstellen und den muss man
eben auf die richtige temperatur bringen
mit einem zucker thermometer und
deswegen ist es jetzt die einfache
möglichkeit gibt ihr die zwei zutaten
von desmond und die bonbons in einen
kleinen topf und es wird erhitzt und
solange gerührt bis sich die bonbons
darin aufgelöst haben
das mache ich jetzt bei etwa mittlere
jetzt das karamell flüssig und da kommen
jetzt noch die erdnüsse mit rein
auch viele erdnüsse ist gut verrühren
zieht es in die form rein gefüllt und
damit später nicht an dem papier klebt
man das ist zwar backpapier und mit
antihaftbeschichtung usw
aber dennoch ist von vorteil wenn man
ein bisschen backt rennspiele noch mit
rein gibt aber man bekommt backpapier
später natürlich auch ohne back
transportweg löst ein bisschen
schwieriger das wird jetzt hier
eingeführt
fries forschung von alleine aber wir
können es noch ein bisschen verteilen
jetzt muss diese erste schicht zuerst
mal richtig abkühlen bevor die zweite
schicht drauf kommt deswegen stelle ich
das jetzt gleich in den kühlschrank und
sei dann so etwa eine halbe stunde bis
stunde und dann können wir die zweite
schicht vorbereiten
die erste schicht ist jetzt abgekühlt
aber ich hab den sneakers riegel
trotzdem noch im kühlschrank und wenn es
die zweite schicht herstellen das ist
diese softe schicht also man kennt das
ja auch zum beispiel von den milchreis
oder von den sneakers riegel wenn man da
rein weist und es war schön soft ist und
dafür sorgt dass marshmallow fleisch und
zwei smart way of life ja eigentlich ein
brotaufstrich den man in amerika ganz
käme auf scoach wird im prinzip besteht
es nur aus eiweiß zucker und stärke und
das kann man jetzt endlich das selber
machen
dafür braucht man aber auch in zucker
thermometer weil man zuckersirup
herstellen muss oder man kauft sich
ebenso selbst nicht selbst holt einfach
und muss nicht selbst herstellen
genau und ich werde es jetzt auch so
machen weil es etwas einfacher ist
aber ich habe auch schon ein rezept auf
meinem blog mit marshmallow klafft bei
meinem alten ich zeig euch jetzt
jedenfalls mal die zutaten ich brauche
für die zweite schicht 120 komponenten
ist 250 gramm zucker 100 gramm butter
120 km etwas butter und 400 gramm
marshmallow blog jetzt nämlich die
ersten drei zutaten alter kondensmilch
zucker und butter und gibt sie in einen
topf und es wird jetzt erhitzt das mache
ich jetzt bei höchster stufe
die masse duft jetzt zwei minuten
aufkochen geht's nämlich sie vom herd
herunter die darf jetzt nämlich nicht so
arg karamellisieren sonst etwas zu fest
das reicht jetzt schon jetzt kommt die
erdnussbutter mit rein
jetzt riecht schon recht nach sneakers
ich finde die kombination karamell und
schokolade richtig toll und jetzt wenn
sich die etwas butter aufgelöst hat und
alles wird verbunden ist kommt das
marshmallows live mit dazu man sieht es
auch schon ganz toll wie locker und
leicht ist
auch wenn es kalorien hat
jetzt wird die creme auf die erste
schicht gefüllt
wo es regional genial aus schmeckt auch
so
um
erst richtig genial was darf ich mal
probiert ein löffel haben am kopf frank
rost er das problem ist wenn das jetzt
einmal probiert also ich finde es
schmeckt so gut diese creme richte sich
aus wie weiße wandfarbe stimmt wurde so
richtig gemacht habe
schmecken die sonne eins zu eins wie es
nichts wie das original des nigers sind
aber weiter nicht zu sagen auch warm und
später wenn es kalt es schmeckt noch mal
besser aber es geht jetzt hier auch
schon diese luftbläschen die können
ruhig mit drin bleiben denn die machen
es ganz richtig locker arbeit muss jetzt
den regeln nochmal kurz kühl stellen für
etwa eine stunde etwa bisher noch mal
fest ist und dann ist es eigentlich
schon so weit und die schokoladen
schicht kann dann nämlich schon drauf
die zweite dicke schicht ist jetzt auch
fest und jetzt muss ich auf die
oberflächen schokolade gießen denn wenig
später den sneakers triegel umdrehe wird
er noch mit schokolade umhüllt und am
boden sondern auch schokolade sein
deswegen hier habe ich jetzt hier
bereits 200 gramm vollmilchpulver türe
fein gehackt und du musst die kuvertüre
temperiert werden damit der überzug
später keinen grauschleier hat und eben
auch fest bleibt bei the water motor
jetzt nehme ich zum temperieren also ist
so beim temperiert ist es so die kubatur
soll ist etwa 29 grad haben und es
bekommt man jetzt so hin indem man jetzt
zwei drittel der cooper türke in ein
heißes wasserbad tipp da habe ich jetzt
freuen das wasser kurz aufkochen lassen
und im herbst wieder ausgestellt
das gebe ich jetzt hier in die schüssel
und da wird dann geschmolzen und ergibt
sich dann auf ungefähr 50 grad und das
restliche drittel und sorgten dafür dass
es gleich wieder runter fühlt aber
natürlich könnt ihr auch ganz einfach im
schokoladen thermometer nehmen aber ohne
thermometer war dass andere die uns
methode
jetzt ist alles geschmolzen jetzt hab
ich's von der schüssel wieder runter
genommen und jetzt muss ich mit dem
restlichen drittel herunterkühlen auf 30
grad oder auf 29 und ich gebe jetzt hier
noch ein stück kokosfett mit rein und
zwar sorgt das kokosfett dafür dass
später die kuvertüre nicht zu fest
werden nicht so gut durch schneiden kann
ohne dass sie eben immer bricht
die kuvertüre die richtige temperatur
und jetzt kann ich sie hier rein füllt
und zwar nur so viel dass der boden
bedeckt ist
hecht stand
und den rest kann ich ja gleich noch für
obendrauf benutzen und zum verteilen
jetzt einfach ein bisschen schütteln der
sneakers regel kommt jetzt noch mal ein
vorletztes mal in den kühlschrank damit
die schokoladen schicht fest und dann
können wir direkt aus stürzen der
sneakers regel sind gut durch gekühlt
jetzt nehme ich ihn aus der frau heraus
am besten nehmen die einen abdruck
gitter das kommt drauf und dann kann man
das schön darauf stürzen
ich musste doch andere tricks aber auf
zügiges gehen raus und am besten noch
ein backpapier unter die form des bitte
gleich mit schokolade übergossen
überzogen
also links setzt übergossen rechts
gezogen
schon richtig aus diesem richtiger
bittet aus dienst erst als die grossen
form wahnsinn karamell dran bist du in
form bringen
also es ist halt schon eine riesen
portion muss man dazu sagen ich will gar
nicht wissen wie viel kalorien so was
hatte ich auch deswegen rechne ich nicht
meistern klengel ist eine heute
ausreichend in die kommentare schreiben
und irgendwie interessiert mich doch ich
glaube ich rechne so jetzt kommt die
korridore drüber da müssen jetzt
aufpassen dass wirklich überall
kommandeure drankommt und sie habe jetzt
übrigens auch wieder temperiert und
wieder mit etwas kokosfett damit sie
einfach etwas geschmeidig bleibt
immer geträumt eine sauerei zu machen
und irgendwie und natur wahrscheinlich
macht es nicht um eure eltern und
erziehern wissen verstreichen
übrigens wäre das nix regel immer
schneller kühl wenn ihr ihn zum beispiel
ins gefrierfach stellt stadt in den
kühlschrank und wenn ja wenn ihr
männlich sein fahrzeug frau in der nähe
ist
das macht das allerdings auch eine
hallig rollen kann nochmal drüber
deswegen ist von irgendwie feministinnen
geht vielleicht schreibt ihr die hitze
alice allison
jetzt kann ich den riesen sneakers
umsetzen und dann muss man noch mal kurz
in den kühlschrank bis die schokolade
fest ist aber das geht auch sehr schnell
da die kuvertüre gerettet
dass necas triegel ist jetzt fertig und
bereits zum verzehr
aber ich zeige euch erstmal das original
also man kann es zu beschenken wo
eigentlich jemand der immer alles prägt
irgendwie ne totale die wahlwerbung und
stimmt ist ein snickers genau ist sie
gast ist ein riesen sneakers für den
monat also hier das original der
original speakers regel unten
diese marshmallow schicht oben die
karamell schlicht mit den ergebnissen
und umhüllt mit vollmilch kuratoren
riecht und schmeckt sehr lecker und
jetzt gesagt ich kann meinem sneakers
auch nicht mehr als ein riegel
das ist einfach viel zu mächtig da ist
der ist voll mit zucker der ist folgen
schokolade der ist also die sohn ist er
nicht aber keine qual
und hier haben wir jetzt auch ganz toll
wurde wahnsinn unten die marshmallows
schicht oben karamell schicht und ich
kein spaß eins zu eins schmeckt besser
besser weil das selbstgemachte kühler
frische und session ohne
konservierungsstoffe und zwar mehrfach
zucker ist ein konservierungsstoff und
haben reichlich drin
okay aber nicht mehr als im original
david boudia hier natürlich möchte ich
so der ausgesteuerten aber das schaffst
du auf keinen fall
ich schneide dir nochmal ein stückchen
ab also ich kann von dem so die hälfte
kann ich essen danach habe ich genug
davon
aber so ein großes stück war schon
heftig dass diese marshmallow schicht
auch wirklich so schön war
wo man kann den regel wirklich super
aufheben also im kühlschrank gelagert
ist mindestens eine woche haltbar
ansonsten einfach ins gefrierfach
stellen und dann auch eiskalt genießen
ist original also falls ihr dieses
rezept auch nach machen wollte da im
marshmallows dann geht auf meinem blog
celtics - blog.de da stets noch mal ganz
genau und ich wünsche euch auf jeden
fall ganz viel spaß beim nachmachen und
falls ihr nicht diesen riesen sneakers
regel machen wollt könnt ihr auch die
kleine version machen
da könnte einfach ein anderes video
anschauen macht es wirklich nur noch
wenn es wenigstens 40 leuten ja
wahnsinnig witzig dann lohnt sondern
richtig geburtstagsparty